et de manière subjective ou qu'il avait
côtoyé pendant de nombreuses années
comment l'imaginez vous vous posez une
question bien délicate au fond ne savons
pas qui est la dame de x la seule chose
que nous fassions avec certitude c'est
que des femmes occuper un rang social
éminent dans la société gauloise
c'était une femme âgés de 30 à 35 ans à
peu près nous avons fait des études sur
le crâne
on a même reconstitué la le visage en
plaquant de l'argile de la matière
plastique offert les muscles et c'était
une femme qui était assez joli c'est à
dire qu'elle peut correspondre à la
légende de conscience est en tout cas
c'est une bauloise c'est une celte ce
n'est pas la princesse on athènes qui
seraient venus de grèce par exemple
1 quelle époque ni vettel bien elle
vivait les mauves faire 35 ans et la
tombe se situe vers 500 ans avant
jésus-christ monsieur masson qui est la
dame du vix selon qui est la dame de vix
répond je ne sais pas au juste ce que
c'était c'était la forme d'un chèque ou
la vie lyncher parce que est mauvaise
les modèles avaient vingt quatre 25 ans
maximum puisqu'il avait encore passée de
la taille de pousser complètement alors
on ne peut pas dire et c'était la femme
d'un chef ou la fille
on ne sait pas au juste mais est-ce
qu'il ya certains c'est elle a été très
la une
une avarie elle a eu le crâne fait alors
que les morts ensuite ça le dtu
princesse druidesse prêtresse et des
partis sans rien laisser d'elles est là
qu'il est vivant ont donné la vie et la
grèce et l'italie qu'il nous suffise de
savoir quelle fut un temps notre grand
mère et notre soeur la plus jolie telle
fille l'éternité de son dernier point
est ce que vous avez trouvé la tombe de
dame de vie les juges
comment vous vous êtes rendu compte
qu'ils avaient quelque chose ici c'est
les pierres qui m'ont fait work avait
quelque chose s'est passé quand portrait
noël et jour de l'an en 1981 2002 et la
fouille et durer combien de temps
ambassades les deux mois et vous
souvenez du jour où vous avez commencé à
creuser 10 et le hallali du travail
parce que ne l'appelle plus commence par
tomber un c'était à lundi je vous dis
dans la même contenu et les jours je
sais la terre n'était pas gelée dur il y
avait de la neige
et vous vous êtes mis à fouiller quand
même et le jour où vous avez découvert
la dame de vix ou souhaite ça et le
brade howie morenz je suis ici tout seul
ah non je vais y avait des gens qui nous
avait aidés
avaaz de bronze et un chariot de bois et
deux chevaux site sur un diadème en or
ont été mis sous terre au pied du mont
lassois sous la pierre et la terre on a
couché son corps la terre a mangé le
corps ainsi hélas loin
lapierre s'est écoulée sur le trésor
depuis les dames cours et verbe il des
ovins le grand cratère a été fabriqué
vraisemblablement en grèce c'est à dire
en italie du sud vers toronto vers cubes
et les autres récipients métalliques ont
été faits vraisemblablement détruit
alors pourquoi des objets qui viennent
de si loin dans une tombe au coeur de la
bourgogne
c'est un problème qui n'a pas encore été
résolu
mais en tout cas cette accumulation de
richesses en bourgogne doit être liée et
surtout dans le châtillonnais doit être
liée avec le commerce de l'état pour
faire du bronze
il faut du cuivre neuf parties et une
partie d'état le pire on trouve assez
facilement mais les teints lui et les
mines d'étain sont situés en angleterre
du sud en cornouailles et l'étain devait
caboter où le minerai d'étain où les
lingots d'état devait capoter le long
des côtes franchir le pas de calais
remonter par la somme l'oise et la seine
et vic c'est précisément le lieu de
rupture de charge
là où la rivière n'est plus navigable et
les princes celte qui commandait
l'oppidum
c'était un verrou ont dû faire payer
très cher le droit de passage et c'est
vraisemblablement pourquoi nous trouvons
des produits italo grecque si nombreux
dans la région
quelques siècles plus tard un château
fut construit en haut du mont lassois la
légende chantée qu un trésor fabuleux il
était enfoui que fantôme et source on
avait le secret les vents les temps
passé sur les blés et puis un paysan de
vix a découvert la clé dans une boucle
de la seine un jour d'hiver on a fouillé
chercher analysé écrit et on a célébré
sur le tombeau ouvert et la gloire et
l'honneur de l'archéologie réveiller
d'un long règne par ce bruit d'enfer
la dame de lille ses revenus de samy
pour sourire d'elle-même comme le
méthane qui lui son poids de 108 kg
surtout si on prend une voie terrestre
rend à transport difficile et vous
remarquerez sur les motifs d'appliquer
qui décorent le col et bien lorsque nous
ont démonté nous avons derrière chaque
relief d'appliquer une marque de montage
qui répétait sur le col du maine et
vraisemblablement il est terminée en
pièces détachées la pub ne pèse que 50
kg tout seul et accompagner surnom d'un
monteur de l'atelier de fabrication à
quoi peut-il servir 12 cents litres ça
fait une tonne et demi lorsqu'il est
placé il vient immeuble par destination
vraisemblablement c'est un vase un
cadeau diplomatique
une anecdote la passoire qui orne le
dessus du cratère a fait penser à
certains que pouvait être une tisane
hier oui va vous sauver en bourgogne
douce en ligne de camomille tilleuls
c'est malvenu
non en réalité
grabataire qui tu n'es pas modèles
réduits mais qui est un modèle géant
imitent les cratères fonctionnel on
connaît des cratères analogue à celui de
vix mais ils font 60 cm de hauteur et
ils ont un couvercle percé de trous
aussi parce que le cratère c'était le
récipient dans lequel on mélangeait le
vin et l'eau car on ne buvait pas le
vaincu c'est une sorte d'apéritif avant
très corsé et qui était aromatisées et
alors on vidait le contenu de l'amphore
et le couvert percée faisait pas soit
rené les aromates
alors je l'aimé comme ceux-ci jeu des
syndicats pas je les relis comme cela je
des cinq cas pas alors je les voyais
bien qu'on le met au dessus mais n'entre
pas dans ma tête ajoute signol voilà
le châtel essentiellement en bois mais
complété en force et ornée des éléments
métalliques
on avait le plan de fuite et ses démos
métallique après une fouille qui était
d'une précision extraordinaire et il a
suffi au moment de la constitution du
chat d'imaginer l'écrasement d'un chat
lance je suis partie de différentes
maquettes et je les écraser et j'ai vu
comment les morceaux pourraient se
répartir l'écrasement n'a pas été tout à
fait verticale ya eu un léger glissement
puisque le toit de l'atome s'est fait
découdre avec un tumulus de pièges peu
de terre trompait les poutres ont
basculé et plusieurs a peut-être une
dizaine de tonnes de pierres sont
dégringolé sur cet ensemble ne sera pas
ses premiers magot lie de l'humanité
c'est le premier a voulu parce que on à
la fois une litière à cause des la
présence des poignets à 4 poignet qui
permettait à quatre porteurs de
transporter cette dame n'ont pas touché
merci je ne suis pas très longs ne se
passe pas au sommet de 45 de long et
ensuite on pose cette litière sur le
châssis il y a des trous de fixation
avec dérivés des clavette ça a été
trouvé cette espèce de pièces
métalliques que l'on croyait être un
petit mot qui sert à fixer le la caisse
solidariser la caisse du du châssis
et alors à ce moment-là on pouvait
transporter la dame c'est dix wagons
lits we say say say say une image montre
assez on a offert les hypothèses
peut-être qu'elle était infirme
peut-être elle avait du mal à se
déplacer
je crois même que l'étude de la santé de
cette dame n'a pas été entièrement faite
anatomy musclé il ya encore de mystère
heureusement
il était une fois une dame inconnue
elle était belle elle était jeune et
elle me
on croyait qu'elle reviendrait dire qui
elle était mais ce n'est pas elle qui
fera le premier pas aux questions qu'on
voudrait lui poser ce thème
et répond aux questions que pose pas
pour la connaître
il faudra l'éternité la suivre là d'où
l'on ne reviendra plus et attendre quand
ça revienne
ce qui fut
où